l'attentât contre le dc10 du téat les
premiers corps des victimes ont été
rapatriés à paris dans le désert du
ténéré l'armée française est chargé de
cette pénible mission rassembler les
cordes et 171 passagers avec une équipe
d'antenne déjà 48 heures de paix où
vivent les réfugiés rentrent à beyrouth
l'aéroport international a été rouvert
le pays n'est plus isolée
300 kilomètres à l'heure 2h04 pour
rallier paris à rennes le premier tgv
atlantique est entré en service
aujourd'hui dimanche reportage à bord
dans cette liste
madame monsieur bonsoir cinq jours après
le drame la sphère du dc 10 d'uta
continue de dominer l'actualité de ce
dimanche soir les enquêteurs ont acquis
désormais la certitude qu'il s'agit bien
d'un attentat à la bombe il cherche
quelle organisation terroriste pourrait
en être le commanditaire deux pistes
s'offrent aux enquêteurs l'afrique qui
n'est pas exempte de conflit et le
proche orient mais aujourd'hui les
organisations proches de l'iran qui se
sentent directement visée nie toute
responsabilité ainsi à beyrouth cet
après midi le chef du mouvement
hezbollah l'ayatollah fadlallah accusent
la france de vouloir nuire à l'image de
l'islam en cherchant de ce côté les
responsables de l'attentât parallèlement
les premiers corps des victimes 171 au
total ont été rapatriés après avoir été
rassemblés sur place dans le désert du
ténéré par l'armée française dans des
conditions très difficiles comme l'ont
constaté et nous envoyés spéciaux
françois corps mais roger mathurin qui
nous présente ce soir les premières
images télévisées tourné au sol sur le
lieu même du drame dans
le désert du ténéré sous des
températures de 45 à 50 degrés les
parachutistes français yves duteil
jamais n'a poursuivent depuis jeudi
dernier leur macabre besogne
récupérer sur une superficie d'une
centaine de kilomètres carrés les restes
des 171 victimes du vol ut 772
parachuté sur la zone après le repérage
de l'épave du dc-10 ses hommes
remplissent ici la mission la plus
délicate est sans doute la plus dure de
leur carrière dans ces sacs de plastique
les premières victimes retrouvées qui
sont évacués par hélicoptère vers agadez
puis acheminés ensuite vers niamey et
paris après avoir été conditionnés dans
des cercueils scellés
les pleurs d'un soldat devant
l'insupportable
c'est une véritable base opérationnelle
que les militaires du dispositif
épervier stationnés au tchad ont mis en
place dans le grand erg du ténéré le
ravitaillement en vivres et en carburant
pour les camions les hélicoptères
s'effectue par aéro largage les
distances sont trop grande dans le
désert pour envisager d'utiliser la
piste
moyens radio et de communication
satellite permettant entre autres au
consul américain de rester en contact au
fur et à mesure des identifications avec
les familles des victimes aux états unis
il faudra encore plusieurs jours aux
parachutistes français pour récupérer le
reste des corps dispersés dans le désert
ou encore prisonniers dans les débris du
dc-10 comme dans cette carcasse calcinée
de la cabine de l'appareil sous laquelle
sans doute dans la soute à bagages à
exploser la bombe
c'est vraisemblablement devant ce
cockpit désintégrer du dc-10 que l'on se
rend mieux compte de ce qui a pu se
passer ici dans les sables du ténéré
tout du moins en altitude au moment de
l'explosion à bord de ce cockpit le
travail et les conversations de
l'équipage se dérouler normalement elles
s'arrêteront brutalement à 650 km de la
capitale tchadienne alors que le dc10
survole le niger pas de message radio
pas de balise de détresse un engins
explosifs de forte puissance a détruit
le vol ut 772 sans que les pilotes et
même eu le temps d'envoyer leurs
derniers messages
pour la première fois depuis six mois ce
sont des bonnes nouvelles qui nous
parviennent du liban depuis 48 heures
très exactement maintenant le cessez le
feu tient bon c'est ce cas précis
aujourd'hui avant tout les libanais
c'est le silence des canons et le bruit
des avions qui ont recommencé à atterrir
sur l'aéroport international de beyrouth
ainsi une tangible d'un retour à la
normale ou presque de lisbonne
depuis quelques heures le liban dans
l'espoir de retrouver la paix pour la
première fois depuis près de deux cents
jours deux avions libanais se sont posée
ce matin sur l'aéroport international de
beyrouth contrôlé par les syriens en
signe d'allégresse des rafales d'armes
automatiques ont été entendus dans la
zone ouest de la capitale pour la
première fois depuis plusieurs mois ces
soldats de l'armée libanaise ont posé
les armes aujourd'hui les forces
syriennes se sont abstenus de pilonner
les positions chrétienne
pour la première fois encore trois
navires marchands ont pu accoster dans
des ports contrôlés par le général aoun
poussé par l'espoir d'une paix pourtant
précaires un grand nombre de libanais
ont regagné beyrouth venant de chip
d'autres se pressaient pour traverser la
ligne est ouest jusqu alors interdite un
cessez-le-feu globalement respecté
aujourd'hui cependant quelques tirs
isolés ont blessé trois civils en pays
chrétien les membres de la commission de
sécurité se réunissait ce dimanche afin
d'envisager la consolidation du
cessez-le-feu
positive également dans un tout autre
domaine il faut le dire cette première
qui ait lieu ce matin en france entre
paris et rennes 350 km en 2h 04 c'est le
temps mis par le tgv atlantique qui est
entré en service ce dimanche matin à
bord une équipe d'antenne 2 jacques
violet frédéric basket
paris montparnasse 8h ce matin la
bretagne à l'heure de la grande vitesse
avec la nouvelle génération des tgv
atlantique la sncf a tendance à comparer
ses trains à des avions les annonces
sont significatives
notre équipage se tient à votre entière
disposition et d'être apte autant
d'heures pour que votre voyage se
déroule dans les meilleures conditions
très vite le train le plus informatisée
du monde 18 ordinateurs à bord pour
gérer la bonne marche et la sécurité
atteint 300 kilomètres dans des
conditions de confort remarquable à
l'intérieur des voitures ainsi que dans
une voiture entièrement réservé au bar
vitesse et confort les atouts que les
premiers voyageurs apprécié il est
spacieux plus grand que l'autre tgv
est agréable
et confortable
je suis ravi de mon voyage dans ce tgv
je trouve les tombes très joli j'aime
les beaux décors
seul ombre au tableau des tarifs
compliqué et quelquefois élevé pour les
suppléments en période de pointe les
premiers tarifs
j'ai vu puisque c'est à partir de saint
brieuc ça peut aller de 29 francs
à 117 francs la réservation ce qui quand
même
relativement cher ce qui fait par
rapport à billets deuxième classe dans
un corail ça fait pratiquement 50%
d'augmentation les élus locaux espèrent
beaucoup du tgv mais gagner une heure ou
deux ne suffira pas à relancer
l'économie régionale en ce qui concerne
le désenclavement de la bretagne c'est
le se faire par l'intermédiaire d'un
tout il y a les routes il y a les voies
aériennes il y a les télécommunications
et le tgv ce qu'il faut c'est que nous
puissions avoir un ensemble diversifié
de moyens de liaison performant très bon
avec le tgv des atouts supplémentaires
pour
nous adresser à notre pays puis pour
avoir notre place au niveau
international
nantes et rennes à deux heures de paris
brest 4 heures au lieu de cinq heures et
demie le tgv atlantique devraient rafler
jusqu'à 50% du trafic avions à air inter
et aux compagnies régionales ce matin
pour ce premier voyage commercial un
clin d'oeil à l'europe ferroviaire nos
amis britanniques suivait le parcours le
trajet en chronométrant notre tgv
nous aimons beaucoup voyagé avec le
chemin de fer français et je regrette
que ce trait à 4 minutes de méthodes de
maintenant à l'arrivée à rennes nos amis
britanniques ont rangé leurs chronos m
le retard était rattrapé l'horaire
respecter ce soir l'honneur est sauf
le cyclone hugo a terminé sa course
dévastatrice au dessus du continent
américain la guadeloupe quant à elle
soigne ses plaies les pouvoirs publics
ont commencé à distribuer des subsides
financiers aux plus démunis mais
l'impatience commence ou même à gagner
certains habitants de l'île c'est ce
qu'ont pu constater et nos envoyés
spéciaux rémy roche et passes captées
d'état
enfin une bâche pour couvrir ce qu'il
reste de sa case presque une privilégiée
car depuis 24 heures des pluies
torrentielles se sont abattues sur la
guadeloupe
ici sur la commune du moule 90% de
l'habitat est sinistré des bâches il en
faudrait deux mille à peine 200 sont
arrivés
paul où dit il a plu abondamment
stagiaires choix c'est ça quand je
demande qu'on me recouvre la maison
préfabriquée un peu
voilà bah à l'entrée de la gendarmerie
sous une tente quelques caisses de
ravitaillement mais ici on ne donne pas
directement la population seuls les
responsables de la distribution dans les
quartiers peuvent s'approvisionner un ou
deux jours de stock d' avance pas plus
du sucre un peu de lait des produits
pour bébés et des rations militaires
mais pratiquement pas d'eau en bouteille
alors que celle du réseau quand ils
fonctionnent fait à la limite du potable
c'est vrai que nous n'avons pas eu
beaucoup beaucoup attendent une
bouteille d'eau par famille
beaucoup il nous en faudrait beaucoup
pour vraiment éviter tout risque tout
risque d'épidémie pour les autres hors
éléments pour les grandes questions il
faudrait le dos
à la mairie on s'y presse dès les
premières heures de la matinée
déclaration des sinistres demandes de
renseignements ou d'assistance
devant et sera place le ton a tendance à
monter ces derniers jours pour fustiger
le faible volume des secours et surtout
pour dénoncer à tord ou à raison les
inégalités dans leur répartition
radio
ces bavardages et
la guadeloupe connaissait des
cataclysmes je pense qu'il faut quand
même être des hommes responsables parce
que ça c'est notre habitude de dire que
les vivront chez parce que non parce que
moi je serai le maire de tous le monde
dont je pense que mes conseillers
municipaux sur le terrain font
exactement pareil il distribue les vip à
ceux qui en ont besoin
dans les quartiers on s'active au plus
urgent déblayés et nettoyés pas
seulement pour oublier le désastre c'est
aussi une nécessité sanitaire ensuite
reconstruire mais avec quels matériaux
déjà presque plus de bois ni même de
cloud plus de tôle pour le moment il
faut se contenter de celle que le
cyclone n'a pas complètement déchiqueté
en bref en belgique la police recherche
toujours une partie de l'avant sont
lancés du haut d'un immeuble par les
complices de philippe delaire qui
souvenez-vous pendant une semaine
avaient retenu une mère et ses deux
enfants en otage un homme a été arrêté
avec une partie de la rançon aujourd'hui
150 mille francs qui l'avait ramassée
sur la chaussée ils n'étaient pas
compile des gangsters mais un simple
badaud il n'avait pas résisté à la
tentation
difficile à comprendre cette affaire que
nous allons vous exposez maintenant à
paris une famille séparer d'un de ses
enfants confie à la dass la direction de
l'action sanitaire et sociale non pas
pour brutalité ou manque d'affection
mais au départ pour une faillite
commercial ensuite eh bien c'est
l'engrenage l'incompréhension entre ses
parents l'administration et la justice
enquête de marque maison neuve et
christian odin à blois en 1979 la vie de
la famille le cellier bascule à cause
d'une faillite pour régler sa dette un
peu plus de deux cent vingt mille francs
madame le celi demande une tutelle
financière une assistante sociale
s'occupera avec celle du dossier l
enquête sur tous les membres de la
famille jean-françois à deux ans de
retard scolaire pour l'assistante
sociale il doit être placé sous la
tutelle de la dass croyant à une banale
remise à niveau madame le cellier sin
school présent il se retrouve à la nasse
uniquement parce qu'il avait un retard
scolaire oui là vers une carte scolaire
moi j'aurais aimé le mettons un
établissement privé je vais pas les
moyens moi j'ai pas les moyens
financiers et on va proposer se disant
un établissement similaire
mais qui est l adage il me dit pas mais
frier je suis pas puisque c'était la
d'acheter très bien et cetera mais
seulement en partie au manque on est
signée qui rentre et normalement il
devait rentrer pour une année donc on
s'engage et le mans pour une ennemie
peu plus le récupérer
jean françois a passé une année scolaire
dans un foyer de seine-et-marne et parce
que le dialogue entre sa mère et le juge
est rompu il va devoir y retourner
jean-françois vous avez envie de
retourner à l'intérieur de ceux de ce
foyer asb non pas du tout
madame le sellier a cru que l'assistante
sociale travaillait pour le bien de son
enfant elle se retrouve devant un juge
avec lequel il lui est impossible de
communiquer un juge qui a refusé de
répondre à nos questions aujourd'hui
madame le sellier a fait appel pour
lutter contre une situation qu'elle vit
comme un déni de justice
car elle s'est aussi aucun de ses trois
autres enfants n'est à l'abri d'une
nouvelle décision judiciaire
un incendie s'est déclaré cet après midi
à l'hôpital de la ciotat près de
marseille dans les bouches du rhône les
dégâts sont importants mais on ne
déplore heureusement aucune victime une
centaine de malades ont tout de même été
évacués des élections discrète mais
importante aujourd'hui en france le
sénat renouveler un tiers de ses sièges
102 au total un scrutin au suffrage
universel indirect c'est à dire ce sont
de grands électeurs qui votent comme les
conseillers régionaux municipaux etc
l'important réside dans les évolutions
de tendances au sein du sénat dominé
actuellement par l'opposition et puis
tout de même quelques combats de
personnes comme à marseille où le maire
robert vigouroux exclu du parti
socialiste a été élu gagnant une
nouvelle fois son combat fratricide
contre ses anciens amis politiques des
résultats tout de suite maintenant avec
rachid arhab au sénat rachid oui daniel
le tout premier enseignement à tirer de
ces élections concernent donc le rapport
droite gauche un rapport qui ne change
pratiquement pas vous allez loire la
droite gagne un siège
la gauche reste stable 90 pour la gauche
230 pour la droite un total global plus
élevé que jusqu'à présent pour la bonne
et simple raison que le sénat
acceuillera deux sénateurs
supplémentaire ils seront au total 321
dans l'hémicycle il nous manque pour
l'instant un seul résultat un dernier
résultat celui de la polynésie mais pour
faire des comparaisons plus fine partie
par partie faudra tout de même patienter
quelques instants mais sachez déjà que
la poussée du rpr du ps attendu a bien
eu lieu parmi les résultats les plus
attendus vous le disiez daniel ceux de
marseille marseille donc avec un grand
vainqueur robert vigouroux en entrant
ici au palais du luxembourg avec deux de
ses colistiers étiqueté majorité
présidentielle robert vigouroux inflige
donc un nouveau camouflet au ps local
qui passe de 5 élus à un seul dans ce
département à droite satisfaction pour
jean claude gaudin jean claude gaudin
qui siègera donc dorénavant au sénat
dans l'autre département test la gironde
les socialistes gagnent un siège voilà
ça c'était jean claude gaudin voici
jacques valade qui est donc élu pour le
rpr à droite dans la gironde à droite va
droit qui a perdu un petit peu de
terrain et qui a donc fait le jeu de la
gauche dans ce département de la gironde
où les socialistes gagnent un siège
toujours parmi les personnalités le miz
la coopération jacques pelletier miss
d'ouverture a eu quelques difficultés à
se faire élire dans l'aisne monsieur
pelletier a dû attendre le deuxième tour
pour conserver son siège sénatorial
enfin entre autres enseignements à tirer
de ce scrutin le parti communiste
gardera son groupe sénatorial tout se
jouer sur l'élection ou non de monsieur
minetti dans les bouches du rhône
monsieur minetti est élu le ps améliore
le pc pardon à bedian même son score en
arrachant un siège plutôt inattendu dans
les côtes du nord il s'agit là d'une des
rares surprises de ces élections
sénatoriales l'une des rares surprises
avec tout de même là la défaite de
monsieur jo dit monique nous vous
annoncions dès 13h monsieur moines et
qui étaient ici le président du groupe
sénatorial de rtp voilà plus de
précision un peu plus tard je pense
daniel merci rachis tout de suite
maintenant des réactions de l'opposition
de la majorité enregistré par
jean-michel mercurol
nous sommes satisfaits parce que nous
avons gagné des sièges dans plusieurs
départements nous avons une déception
pourquoi le cacher concernant les
bouches du rhône mais nous constatons
que les trois élus de la liste vigouroux
dans les bouches du rhône se réclamer de
la majorité présidentielle il reste donc
à savoir où ils s'inscriront lorsqu'ils
arriveront au sénat le groupe du sénat
socialiste est ouvert aux jeunes mais
c'est vite vu le groupe socialiste au
sénat est ouvert à tous ceux qui se
réclament de la majorité présidentielle
ce qu'est leur carte donc nous verrons
quelle sera leur propre attitude nous
avons tout lieu de nous réjouir ce soir
tout d'abord parce que les résultats des
élections sénatoriales
son bond pour l'ensemble de la majorité
sénatoriale et ils sont particulièrement
satisfaisant pour le groupe rpr nous
étions car nous étions 80 nous serons de
mer plus de 90 et nous avons donc tout
lieu d'être satisfait
non monsieur première nous a indiqué ce
soir qu'il était candidat je n'ai jamais
fait mystère de mes sentiments je
considère que le prix et d'emploi à la
fois bien servi le sénat et la faute
alors les groupes politiques se pressent
détermineront mais il est bien évident
qu'en ce qui me concerne je souhaite sa
ex la commenter a maintenant politique
de jean-louis 200 jours au sénat jean
louis oui vous savez daniel les
transformations au sénat se font très
lentement et en douceur et découle
directement du mode de scrutin que vous
rappeliez tout à l'heure le tiers
seulement de la haute assemblée est
renouvelé tous les trois ans
autre particularité ce sont les élus des
dernières élections nationales et
locales notamment des récentes municipal
qui votait aujourd'hui résultats donc
une poussée socialiste et un rpr
conforté dans son rôle de premier groupe
du sénat alors que le centre connaît lui
des revers d'importance le rdr
l'ancienne gauche démocratique et plus
particulièrement les radicaux de gauche
apparaissent bien ce soir comme les
grands perdants de la consultation
d'aujourd'hui
deuxième constatation un certain
rajeunissement de la haute assemblée dû
au retrait volontaire d'une trentaine de
sénateurs dont certains siègent est ici
au palais bourg depuis 1958 reste le
problème du troisième tour autrement dit
l'élection du président du sénat alain
poher a dit qu'il attendrait d'avoir
tous les résultats aujourd'hui pour
annoncer s'il serait candidat ou non à
sa propre succession et bien c'est fait
monsieur power vient de dire au
président du groupe de la majorité
sénatoriale qu'il briguera effectivement
à nouveau le siège de président du sénat
nous vous retrouvons à 23h pour une
émission spéciale avec cette fois tous
les résultats pour les réactions et tous
les commentaires merci messieurs à tout
à l'heure devant ce résultat à partir de
23 heures dans une émission spéciale
pour ces élections sénatoriales le
conflit peugeot entre dans sa quatrième
semaine le pdg de psa jacques calvet ne
veux pas vous savez aller plus loin dans
ses propositions salariales dans une
interview au journal les échos à
paraître demain le président des cadres
cgc paul marchelli affirme qu'il est
honteux ce sont ses propres termes
d'utiliser les cadres comme briseurs de
grève à mulhouse et à sochaux quant au
premier ministre lui-même monsieur
michel rocard aux assises de
l'entreprise organisées par le parti
socialiste
sans évoquer précisément le conflit
peugeot il déclare donc aujourd'hui que
les entreprises ont besoin cercle d'une
gestion rigoureuse mais il ajoute les
conflits surgissent souvent d'une
insuffisance de dialogue social monsieur
rocard ce qui est fondamentalement en
jeu dans le débat sur le pouvoir d'achat
est en effet
non seulement le pouvoir d'achat
lui-même mais la modernisation des
relations sociales dans ce pays
pourquoi parce que les conflits
surgissent le plus souvent d'une
insuffisance de dialogue social
c'est clair
y compris dans les sts est de la france
aujourd'hui
parce que toutes les frustrations
convergent alors sous forme de
revendications salariales
même quand leurs origines ne l'est pas
seulement
que leur accumulation rend impossibles à
satisfaire toujours toujours monsieur
bérégovoy le ministre de l'économie et
des finances au grand jury rtl le monde
chez peugeot dit-il j'espère que la
discussion aura lieu je peux comprendre
la direction ajoute-t-il direction de
peugeot mais je dois aussi comprendre
les salariés l'histoire nous dira s'il
s'agit d'une date et d'un lieu
historique cet après midi à evry dans la
banlieue parisienne et le front chinois
d'opposition premier parti politique
autre que le pc chinois à voir le jour
depuis 1948 date de la naissance de la
république populaire de chine à la tête
de ce mouvement les étudiants des
intellectuels exilés depuis la reprise
en main au mois de juin dernier à pékin
c'est dans un décor de western
véritablement qu'américains et
soviétiques viennent de signer plusieurs
accords de désarmement stratégique
nucléaire le secrétaire d'état américain
james baker et le ministre des affaires
étrangères soviétique monsieur edouard
chez vernazza étaient réunis dans un
ranch du wyoming l'occasion également
d'annoncer un sommet bouche gorbatchev
au printemps ou l'été prochain marque
maison de george bush le président
américain a interrompu sa partie de golf
pour annoncer la nouvelle aux états unis
au cours du printemps prochain au début
de l'été 1990 se tiendra un sommet
américano soviétique c'est la première
fois qu'une telle rencontre entre
michail gorbatchev et george bush aura
lieu
les artisans de la rencontre edouard
chevardnadzé et james baker les
entretiens de jackson hole ont duré
trois jours ils ont porté sur ce que
l'on appelle la guerre des étoiles et
l'accord start concernant la réduction
des arsenaux stratégiques
apparemment les soviétiques ne lit plus
ces deux questions ces discussions
largement dépasser les estimations les
plus optimistes en plein wyoming
l'ambiance était détendue on a même
parlé d'un accord visant à améliorer les
relations entre les eskimos habitants de
part et d'autre du détroit de béring
l'annnonce du sommet en version
américaine part d'un bon pied
la plupart des spécialistes il faut bien
le dire se sont trompé dans l'analyse du
conflit afghan en effet au mois de
février dernier après le départ des
dernières troupes soviétiques qu'il
pensait généralement que le régime mis
en place par moscou allait tomber comme
un fruit mûr face à la résistance à
l'image du gouvernement sud vietnamiens
après le départ des américains en 1973
force est de constater que rien ne s'est
passé comme prévu pourquoi reportage
d'emilien jubineau une gerbe aux
commentaires de jérôme bonnes
scènes de la vie quotidienne à kaboul
ce sont le plus souvent des femmes et
des enfants qui meurent sous des
roquettes tirées de trop loin par les
moudjahidine preuve de l'impuissance de
la résistance dans la capitale incapable
de frapper juste contre des cibles
militaires
sept mois après le retrait des troupes
soviétiques qui devait signer son arrêt
de mort l'homme fort du régime installé
par moscou le président lundi lula est
toujours là chaque jour qui passe lui
fait gagner un peu de crédit aux montées
aux yeux du monde
à la déception de beaucoup de diplomates
l'afghanistan n'est pas le vietnam
soviétique ne serait ce qu'à cause de
cette longue frontière commune il ya une
semaine un convoi de 13 cents véhicules
soviétique dont 300 chars a gagné kandar
pratiquement sans perte
tapi dans leur bunker de kaboul des
conseillers soviétiques en voie de
redoutables missiles ce code autour de
djalal abad toujours encerclée par les
moudjahidine
sept mois après le retrait du contingent
soviétique la guerre afghane coûte
encore extrêmement cher à moscou mais
grâce à cela les grandes villes tiennent
toujours
à quelques exceptions près taloqan aux
portes de la province de tarare le
grenier à blé de kaboul taloqan ville de
50000 habitants est sous contrôle des
moudjahidine
les populations sont revenus le marché
est approvisionné
la vie semble presque normal même si la
menace d'un bombardement est permanente
nous sommes en plein secteur contrôlé
par le commandant massoud le seul chef
de la résistance considéré par les
soviétiques eux mêmes comme un
interlocuteur valable
les difficultés que le lion du panshir
rencontre ici illustre bien ces
dissensions entre factions de
moudjahidine qui elles aussi font le jeu
de kaboul ce commandant d'un groupe
islamiste concurrents a fait exterminer
15 hommes de massoud il attend son
jugement en fait par delà ces
dissensions les échecs militaires de la
résistance s'explique selon massoud par
trop de précipitation mais d'une et asic
et moudjahidine avorté d'achat volcan
les soviétiques étaient là faust nous
étions dans une position défensive après
leur départ il faut du temps pour passer
à l'offensive
en dessous des pressions diplomatiques
certes un groupe de moudjahidine se sont
lancés trop vite dans une guerre de
position à laquelle ils n'étaient pas
préparés
interrompu en novembre l'aide américaine
aux moudjahidine a repris aujourd'hui
massoud a levé une armée de 7500 hommes
parmi lesquels curieusement sept soldats
soviétiques capturés et contraint à la
guerre sainte pour sauver leur peau le
lion du panchir vient de lancer une
vaste offensive au nord de kaboul mais
la capitale elle même s'est dit il pour
plus tard dans un an peut-être
le sport maintenant quelle histoire cet
après midi sur le circuit de formule1
d'estoril au portugal c'est l'autrichien
berg air sur ferrari qui a remporté le
grand prix devant le français alain
prost quant à ses règles et il a été
sorti de la route certains diront même
balancé dans des conditions obscures par
nigel mansell et quand on sait que
mansell sera la saison prochaine chez
ferrari le coéquipier de prost certains
s'interrogent toleman
39e tour nigel mansell en tête du grand
prix sar est à son stand pour un
changement de pneumatiques mais regardez
il s'arrête trop loin alors il est
obligé de passer la marche arrière mais
voilà c'est une manoeuvre
conséquence quelques tours plus tard
commissaires de course agite rare au
noir mansell disqualifié mais le
britannique ne s'arrête pas tout tour 3
tours même et puis le dépasser sénat et
là c'est l'accident
les deux voitures ne repartiront pas ce
qui fait la ferme libert guerre seul en
tête et surtout d'alan gross qui devient
deuxième
chacun ses problèmes et un
bon j'en ai eu un à une époque aussi on
verra bien géré c'est une saison très
très difficile pour nous pour nous tous
dans l'équipe pour lui comme pour moi et
j'ai certainement beaucoup plus de champ
seulement actuelle mais c'est peut-être
une justice aussi
est donc grave des regards qui s'impose
dans ce treizième grand prix devant
alain prost qui marque 6 points précieux
et stefan johansson qui amène pour la
première fois l'écurie aux knicks sur le
podium au classement du championnat pro
tu m'étonnes grand pas vers le tiff il
faut désormais cartonne sénat remporté
les trois derniers grands prix pour
devenir champion du monde
sans contestation maintenant enfin une
victoire pour le français laurent fignon
vainqueur du grand prix des nations 6
pouces devant le suisse vers müller et
un autre français 3e charly mottet
aujourd'hui laurent fignon disposer du
fameux guidon aérodynamique qui avait
permis à l'américain greg lemond de le
battre dans la dernière étape contre la
montre du tour de france en juillet
dernier
voici maintenant un sport que les
français n'ont jamais très bien compris
le cricket cher à nos voisins anglais q
uand tout compris et pourtant et bien
cet après midi à meudon un club français
a battu la plus célèbre équipe anglaise
dans un match reporté de deux cents ans
en effet le mari de bonnes cricket club
s'apprêtait à franchir la manche en
juillet 1789 quand la révolution éclate
à à paris reportage de valérie fournier
et didier da
l'ellure et élégante dans cette arène où
les passions sont toutes britannique
flegmatique le cricket ou le base-ball
version soft l'équipe de france n'avait
pas joué depuis les jeux olympiques de
1920 comble elle avait pourtant reçu
alors la médaille d'argent mais si cette
rencontre est historique c'est qu'elle
commémore le premier match entre la
france et l'angleterre prévu en 1789
match qui n'eut jamais lieu dans le
fracas révolutionnaire quand la
fédération française de cricket le
comité de cricket s'est reconstitué ya
trois ans farrel jamais imaginé que le
mcc viendrait nous faire l'honneur
je suis très heureux et c'est vraiment
pour une chose de fantastique de jouer
contre les m messieurs les anglais tirez
les premiers le cricket est un sport de
gentlemen dont le but est d'éliminer les
joueurs adverses et bien sûr de marquer
des points ou lancer de la balle ces
règles remonte au 12e siècle dans la
plus pure tradition britannique
ici on respecte la décision de l'arbitré
et le tea time
cela ressemble à une garden party c'est
très relax isn't it
tout à fait c'est la petite angleterre
reconstitué à meudon la forêt c'est un
jeu qu'on doit jouer il faut être il
faut être calme il faut être tranquille
est-ce que vous pensez que les français
sont suffisamment calme pour jouer au
cricket c'est pour moi dans le nord est
mais peut-être pas dans le midi quelques
fois et pourtant face aux clubs les plus
prestigieux du monde le mari le bun
cricket club d'angleterre la france
vient de gagner avec 165 points et
seulement trois éliminés contre 164
points et c'est éliminer anglais une
victoire de taille est historique voilà
cool maintenant le tiercé et le quarté +
pour gagner le tiercé vous jouez dans
l'ordre par compliqué le 9 le 10 et le
11 et pas besoin de pronostiqueurs et
pour ce qui concerne le kart est là il
faut ajouter le 7 pour gagner un petit
peu moins de dix mille francs
voilà ce journal est terminée tout de
suite après les prévisions météo du
début de semaine avec josé blanc
lapierre spécial résultats sénatoriale
aux alentours de 23 heures suivi du
journal présenté par philippe gas invité
des 4 vérités demain matin à 7h45 pierre
joxe ministre de l'intérieur qui doit
recevoir dans la journée de lundi la
phase peu le principal syndicat de
police et qui commentera également
sûrement le résultat des élections
sénatoriales quant à moi je vous
retrouverai d'abord mardi soir pour un
star à la barre consacré aux vedettes
qui vendent un peu trop facilement leur
image pour des produits miracles qui ne
sont pas forcément et puis bien sûr nous
nous retrouvons samedi prochain avec
toute l'équipe du week-end bonsoir bonne
semaine